it's a millionaire theme our we're
talking to real millionaires not
mythical ones and finding out what they
did and how they did it if you're a
millionaire it's not because you make a
million dollars a year it's because your
net worth is a million dollars or
greater what you own minus what you owe
Jonathan is with us in Tucson hey
Jonathan how are you hey mr. Anthony
nice talking to you you too man so what
is your net worth sir I'm just over a
million at one point oh five million
okay just got there congratulations well
done
and what's the mix on that of that how
much of that's what about 305 in my
personal residence real estate about 310
and retirement 300 and investments and
then I got about a hundred and thirty
and cash good for you very cool and uh
how old are you I'm 32 you're a young
millionaire way to go so how much of
this did you inherit I haven't heard all
of here oh okay okay so I'm guessing
you've been making some Bank what's your
income I'm about a five hundred fifty
thousand a year Wow there we go that's
what that explains it what do you do for
a living
I'm not dental anesthesiologist so I put
a dental patient to sleep for the
dentists and make sure they're doing D
about air sleep okay so obviously you
have a degree as an it as an anesthetist
yes I have a dental degree and then I
did a residency afterwards okay Wow
and your GPA about three point nine nine
throughout the whole time okay so you
are genius okay okay
fun very fun so uh how much of your
wealth is due to you borrowing money I
think that's an easy answer it would be
zero because you you have is just a huge
fabulous income right well you know I
actually before I met you had gone into
about 250 thousand dollars of debt of
with dental school and I met a guy well
one of my friends Henry felt like he
just got a debt-free stream on the show
in May he introduced me to you in 2012
and you know I was making this money but
I have nothing to show for it really you
know I know maybe I'll pay this off in
about 20 years and so and once I got
onto your plan I just you know I got
things lined up and you know four years
later Here I am a millionaire Oh
congratulations I'm so proud of you very
very well done that's awesome man you're
killing it very cool thank you for so um
man this is cool so what part has giving
played in your financial plan I give
about you ten or just over ten percent
my income per year
you know my parents I believe that
Jellicle Christian and was raised to
type so I tied every year and then they
were able to give you know over that as
well and there's something that I see
that you know some cause I want to get
to you or something I want to get you so
about fifty fifty five thousand a year
cool cool non-medical how many books a
year do you read I'm doing about one to
two a month and really you know what I
got I mean I've always I love to read
but really when I got on your your plan
and you know you say you read one book a
month you stuff with millionaires dude I
want to be a millionaire so I'm reading
one or two books a month they're loose
right now
cool what's the favorite book you've
read lately I'm in the middle of a
billionaire mind by Tom's family so what
kind of fitting for today's call yeah
absolutely that's where he studied the
deck of millionaires in that right hey
Jacko so hopefully I'll be in that
category real good yeah you will be at
the rate you're going you're killing it
very cool
so your advice to young docs coming out
making Bank but just kind of coast along
spinning at all what would your advice
to them be well I would say if you can't
avoid the debt going into it that gives
us you know I don't know how you know if
you got to go different school go to
military route but your best bet if
you're ready in it and you got a you're
in the situation you have a couple
hundred thousand dollars in debt I would
say get on the Dave Ramsey plan and once
you get out you got to live below your
means you know that's really what I did
is look through all my means save the
bunch and and you shoot a kit with a
huge four up you know ferocity it's gone
cool well way to go dude I'm proud of
you very well done you're a hero
well done well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you got two
hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or twenty seven
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or a five hundred
thousand dollar income